cuz don't know it God just asleep  fiancee dropped another surprise visual  on us but it's not what you think  [Music]  Tuesday mark beyoncé and jay-z's 9th  wedding anniversary and in honor of the  day they cemented their Kingdom Queen  Bee dedicated a new version of die for  you to her man I don't have a reason to  cry in the video streaming only on title  home videos of the Power couples secret  wedding romantic getaways and yes even  the birth of Blue Ivy the Beehive was  also treated to a glimpse of bees  growing baby bump complete with kisses  from big sis blue Beyonce has clearly  been enjoying her pregnancy and slaying  her maternity fashion but we need now is  B to pop out those twins because you  know that next album is gonna be fire oh  yeah I like that  [Music]